una celebración digna de una boda frente
a este cine de bombay un millar de fans
celebra el regreso de su estrella tras
cuatro años de ausencia de las pantallas
sharrukan y su nueva película patrón
los numerosos llamamientos al boicot no
consiguieron acabar con la película en
las últimas semanas grupos
fundamentalistas próximos al Primer
Ministro narendra modi han llevado a
cabo acciones violentas en cines de todo
el país
[Música]
el bikini color azafrán de la actriz de
pica padukonen un color sagrado en el
hinduismo y la camisa verde de charrukan
que a sus ojos recuerda el islam fueron
temas polémicos
porque solo se dirigen a esa película
porque se centran en esa película es por
su nombre musulmán siempre tiene que
repetir que aunque se llame can no es un
terrorista se ha convertido en un hábito
son polígmicas inútiles que hacen los
partidos políticos para llamar la
atención nada más patrón se ha
convertido en el mejor arranque de la
historia para una película India pero la
junta de la censura seguía ordenando
recortes un paso obligatorio para
cualquier película que desee estrenarse
los cines desnudez u obscenidad los
directores como alancrita shery bastaba
deben cumplir las normas su última
película
La historia de cuatro mujeres Rebeldes
fue rechazada inicialmente por ser
demasiado feminista nos piden que
eliminemos algunas palabras que
cambiemos otras que cortemos algunas
escenas es una especie de Norma cultural
en la India en un país democrático no
debe haber censura ya sea en el arte la
literatura una película o un libro en
los últimos años han aumentado los
ataques a la industria de bollywood por
parte estas hindúes como resultado los
productores se censuran a sí mismos lo
mismo ocurre con las plataformas de
streaming la última película de diva car
benergy narra la intolerancia religiosa
que sufren los musulmanes en la India
puede que nunca vea la luz en Netflix Se
observa la aparición de una especie de
falso Patriotismo un Patriotismo que
busca atacar a un enemigo por ejemplo un
país extranjero o a los musulmanes la
extrema derecha puede atacarte cada
película que se estrena sabe que se
enfrentará a una docena de demandas
Aunque por ahora escapen a la censura
las plataformas de streaming temen ahora
por su libertad artística en la India